JOHN BERMAN IS HERE TO BREAK
DOWN THE KEY RACES THAT ARE
STILL UNDECIDED, I'M HAVING DEJA
VU STANDING AT THIS WALL.
>> I APOLOGIZE.
KAITLAN WALKS OVER AND I SAID
DON'T BOTHER ME I'M DOING MATH.
IT'S HARD.
>> IT'S LOOKING BETTER FOR
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE RIGHT
NOW.
>> IT MIGHT BE.
WE ARE WATCHING, OF COURSE,
NEVADA AND ARIZONA.
IF EITHER PARTY MANAGES TO WIN
BOTH OF THESE STATES THEN WE
DON'T NEED TO WAIT UNTIL THE
RUNOFF IN GEORGIA TO FIGURE OUT
WHO WINS CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
LET'S SEE WHERE WE ARE IN
NEVADA.
SO NOW, ADAM LAXALT, THE
REPUBLICAN, LEADS THE INCUMBENT
DEMOCRAT, CATHERINE CORTEZ
MASTO, BUT JUST BY 9,000 VOTES.
LET ME SEE IF I CAN TELL YOU
WHERE THIS WAS YESTERDAY WHEN WE
WERE TALKING MOST OF THE DAY.
MOST OF THE DAY YESTERDAY,
LAXALT WAS AHEAD BY 15,000 MAYBE
MORE.
NOW THE LEAD HAS SHRUNK TO ABOUT
9000.
WHY?
THERE WERE MORE VOTES COUNTED IN
WASHOE COUNTY YESTERDAY, ABOUT
18000.
AND CATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO
NETTED ABOUT 60% OF THIS AT.
AND 12,000 VOTES COUNTED IN
CLARK LAST NIGHT, CATHERINE
CORTEZ MASTO WON 61% OF THAT.
I GIVE YOU THESE PERCENTAGES
BECAUSE THE MATH HERE IS
INTERESTING.
LET'S GO TO BLANK BLACK BOARD.
WE THINK THERE ARE ROUGHLY, LET
ME GET THIS OUT, WE THINK THERE
ARE ROUGHLY 95,000 VOTES LEFT TO
COUNT --
>> IN THE WHOLE STATE?
>> IN THE WHOLE STATE OF NEVADA.
95,000 VOTES.
IF SHE CAN WIN 60% OF THAT,
WHICH SHE WAS YESTERDAY IN
WASHOE AND CLARK COUNTY, SHE
WOULD NET 19,000 VOTES.
WHICH EVEN WITH MY MATH SKILLS I
KNOW --
>> WOULD CHANGE THAT.
>> IS MORE THAN THE 9,000 VOTES.
I DON'T KNOW THIS WILL HAPPEN.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU DIRECTIONALLY
WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF THE MARGINS
STAY THE SAME.
WE KNOW THERE'S 50,000 VOTES
LEFT IN CLARK COUNTY.
WE DON'T KNOW IF SHE'LL BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THAT TYPE OF MARGIN
THERE.
IN ARIZONA, A DIFFERENT STORY.
MARK KELLY, THE DEMOCRAT HAS
EXPANDED HIS LEAD AS MORE VOTE
COUNTING HAS BEEN RECORDED
TYPICALLY IN MARICOPA COUNTY,
ESPECIALLY MARICOPA COUNTY.
HE HAD BEEN AT 85,000 YESTERDAY
NOW AT 115,000.
ABOUT 540,000 VOTES LEFT TO
COUNT.
THAT'S A LOT.
A LOT OF RUNWAY.
IF THAT VOTE SKEWS REPUBLICAN
AND BLAKE MASTERS GETS 60% OF
THAT, HE COULD GET CLOSE TO
OVERTAKING MARK KELLY.
BUT THERE ARE ABOUT THREE
COUNTIES ALMOST 100% IN, THEY'RE
ALL REPUBLICAN COUNTIES, JUST
WEST OF PHOENIX YOU CAN SEE 95%,
MAY BE MORE, MARK KELLY IS
OUTPERFORMING JOE BIDEN.
WHAT JOE BIDEN DID THERE BY 7.5
POINTS.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY BIDEN WON
ARIZONA?
>> BARELY BUT HE WON IT.
GRAHAM COUNTY, MARK KELLY IS
OUTPERFORMING JOE BIDEN BY 7
POINTS HERE.
AND WEST GREENLY, IT'S TINY BUT
HE'S OUTPERFORMING WHAT JOE
BIDEN DID THERE RIGHT NOW BY 17
POINTS.
SO YES --
>> REMARKABLE.
>> -- WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR ALL
THIS TO COME IN THERE IS ENOUGH
ROOM FOR BLAKE MASTERS IF HE
DOES WELL IN THE REST OF THE
VOTE TO OVERTAKE MARK KELLY.
BUT IN THE PLACES WE'VE SEEN
ALMOST EVERYTHING MARK KELLY IS
DOING WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO
WIN.
>> SEEMS LIKE THAT'S SOMEWHERE
DEMOCRATS ARE WAKING UP GOOD
NEWS.
HOW MANY VOTES LEFT IN NEVADA?
>> 95,000.
>> HOW LONG IS THAT GOING TO
TAKE?
MY DAD CALLED ME AFTER THE SHOW
SAID WHY IS THIS TAKING TOO
LONG.
I SAID IT'S NORMAL, HAPPENED TWO
YEARS AGO.
>> IN NEVADA, THE LAW SAYS THAT
ANY BALLOT POSTMARKED BY
ELECTION DAY CAN BE RECEIVED
UNTIL ACTUALLY TOMORROW AND THEY
WILL BE COUNTED.
SO THEY'RE JUST WAITING FOR ALL
THOSE TO COME IN AS THEY
CONTINUE TO PROCESS.
ARIZONA IT JUST TAKES SOME TIME.
THEY GET THE VOTES IN, MATCH THE
SIGNATURES WITH THE THINGS ON
FILE.
THEY WERE SLOW TWO YEARS AGO,
THEY'RE SLOW THIS TIME.
BUT ARIZONA, NO ONE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH ARIZONA DOING THIS
UNTIL ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO WHEN
PEOPLE CALL RESULTS INTO
QUESTION.
THIS IS HOW ARIZONA HAS DONE IT
FOR SOME TIME.
>> IT'S NORMAL.
>> IT COULD TAKE ANOTHER WEEK IN
ARIZONA.
>> WE'LL ORDER YOU BREAKFAST.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
>> APPRECIATE IT.
>> BERMAN IS GOOD AT MATH AND
MAGIC BERMAN AT THE WALL.
>> I HAVE TO PREPARE THE MATH, I
CAN'T READ MY HANDWRITING.
A LOT OF CHALLENGES HERE.
>> DO YOU WANT SOME CHEESE TO GO
WITH THAT WHINE?
>> COME ON.
MATH WAS NOT PART OF THE JOB
WHEN WE SIGNED UP FOR
JOURNALISM.
>> BE NICE TO BERMAN WE NEED HIM
AT THE WALL.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT GEORGIA
WITH THE RUNOFF CAMPAIGN BETWEEN
RAPHAEL WARNOCK AND HERSCHEL
WALKER UNDER WAY, SO MUCH MONEY
IS POURING INTO THIS STATE.
IN THE PAST 24 HOURS, BOTH
PARTIES, OUTSIDE GROUPS,
ANNOUNCED INVESTMENTS IN THIS
RACE THAT COULD DETERMINE THE
BALANCE OF POWER IN THE SENATE.
STAGGERING AMOUNTS OF MONEY WERE
SPENT IN OTHER BATTLEGROUND
STATES AS WELL.
SOME REPUBLICANS ARE QUESTIONING
WHETHER IT WAS ENOUGH.
LET'S GO TO RAHEL SOLMAN.
WHEN YOU HAVE STATES WITH TIGHT
MARGINS THERE'S MONEY MORNING
QUARTERBACKING IF WE JUST POURED
MORE MONEY INTO THE STATES.
>> A LOT OF MONEY TO FOLLOW.
LET'S START WITH FIVE SENATE
RACES, BOTH PARTIES, CAMPAIGNS
AND OUTSIDE GROUPS COMBINED TO
SPEND OVER $1 BILLION.
LET THAT SINK IN.
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST, MY HOME
STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA,
$264 MILLION.
DEMOCRAT JOHN FETTERMAN HERE
DEFEATING REPUBLICAN MEHMET OZ.
REPUBLICANS OUTSPENDING
DEMOCRATS BY $22 MILLION IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
NORTH TO NEW HAMPSHIRE WHERE
DEMOCRAT MAGGIE HASSAN DEFEATED
DON BOLDUC REPUBLICANS
OUTSPENDING HERE.
AND THEN TO GEORGIA, WHERE
REPUBLICANS SPENT ABOUT 22
MILLION MORE HERE.
>> CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE RACES
AND WHAT WE KNOW.
>> LET'S START WITH ARIZONA,
MARK KELLY, STILL MAINTAINING
HIS EDGE OVER BLAKE MASTERS
THERE THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE.
DEMOCRATS OUTSPENT REPUBLICANS
BY $46 MILLION.
IN NEVADA, WHERE ADAM LAXALT IS
LEADING CATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO,
DEMOCRATS OUTSPEND REPUBLICANS
HERE BY $17 MILLION.
LET'S LOOK AT THE SPENDING
ADVANTAGE.
YOU CAN SEE THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
STATES I MENTIONED PLUS OHIO.
DEMOCRATS OUTSPENDING IN STATES
LIKE ARIZONA, NEVADA, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, REPUBLICANS
OUTSPENDING IN STATES LIKE OHIO
AND PENNSYLVANIA.
FOR FOLKS AT HOME WHO PERHAPS
HAVE AD CAMPAIGN FATIGUE.
THIS IS WHY IT WAS A LOT OF
MONEY, ADS AND OUR FRIENDS IN
GEORGIA THEY HAVE A FEW MORE
WEEKS OF IT.
>> A FEW MORE WEEKS AND A LOT OF
ADS TO COME.
CNN SENIOR DATA REPORTER HARRY
INTON IS AT THE BATTLEGROUND
DESK FOR US THIS MORNING.
WHAT'S GOING TO GO DOWN ON
DECEMBER 6th?
>> I FEEL LIKE IT'S DEJA VU ALL
OVER AGAIN.
GEORGIA RUNOFF RULES ARE SIMPLE.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD THE ELECTION
ON -- JUST ON TUESDAY.
THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
RUNOFF BETWEEN THE TOP TWO VOTE
GETTERS, RAPHAEL WARNOCK AND
HERSCHEL WALKER BECAUSE NEITHER
REACHED A MAJORITY 50 PLUS ONE
IN THE ELECTION.
THE NEW ELECTION IS ON DECEMBER
6th.
RUNOFFS HAVE BEEN A SYSTEM IN
GEORGIA DEVELOPED IN THE 1960s.
DEVELOPED BY WHITE LAWMAKERS WHO
WANTED TO ASSURE THAT THE WHITE
MAJORITY POPULATION WOULD BE
ULTIMATELY ABLE TO DECIDE WHO
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS WOULD BE
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID BLACK
VOTERS COULD ELECT THEIR
CANDIDATES IN PLURALITY IN THE
60s BECAUSE OF PERHAPS A DIVIDED
FIELD IN THE WHITE CANDIDATES.
NOT THE CASE TODAY.
IT IS A RELIC.
>> NOT THE FIRST TIME GEORGIA'S
SENATE RACE WAS DIVIDED IN A
RUNOFF.
>> IT'S NOT.
IF YOU GO BACK SINCE 1992 WE'VE
HAD A BUNCH OF RUNOFFS
STATEWIDE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TENDED TO DO
BETTER ON THE WHOLE.
DONE BETTER IN THE RUNOFF SEVEN
OUT OF TEN TIMES.
OF COURSE, THE 2021 RUNOFFS WERE
AN EXCEPTION TO THAT WHERE BOTH
THE DEMOCRATS DID BETTER.
WHY WAS 2021 DIFFERENT THAN THE
OTHER YEARS?
I THINK THE TURNOUT GIVES YOU AN
INDICATION.
LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS SENATE RUNOFF TURN OUT
AS A PERCENTAGE OF THE GENERAL
ELECTION TURNOUT.
NORMALLY RUNOFF TURN OUT TRAILS
BY A SIGNIFICANT MARGIN.
BUT IN THE 2021 IT BASICALLY
MATCHED ONLY SLIGHTLY LOWER.
WHY WAS IT SLIGHTLY LOWER?
IT WAS BECAUSE OF BLACK
TURNOUTS.
BLACKS HAVE TURNED OUT IN
GEORGIA IN LOWER NUMBERS IN THE
RUNOFFS THAN GENERAL ELECTION.
BUT 2021 WAS THE OPPOSITE.
THE VOTE OF BLACK COUNTIES WAS
LARGE COMPARED TO WHITE
COUNTIES.
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN THIS TIME
BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT DEMOCRATS WOULD LOVE TO
SEE.
I THINK THERE'S A BIG QUESTION
ULTIMATELY, THOUGH.
WHAT WILL GEORGIA BE
DETERMINING?
WILL IT DETERMINE CONTROL OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE OR WILL IT
BE THE CASE THAT ARIZONA AND
NEVADA GO TO ONE PARTY AND THAT
WOULDN'T OCCUR.
SAY GEORGIA IS NOT DETERMINING
CONTROL OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATING, I THINK THAT'S WELCOME
NEWS FOR DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE IF WE ASK IF IT WAS
IMPORTANT, IF YOU DIDN'T CARE
WHO CONTROLLED THE UNITED STATES
SENATE, RAPHAEL WARNOCK HAD A
LARGE ADVANTAGE OVER HERSCHEL
WALKER WHICH I THINK GETS BACK
TO THE IDEA OF CANDIDATE
QUALITY.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER EVEN IF THEY
DIDN'T LIKE HIM BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO ASSURE REPUBLICANS GOT
CONTROL.
IF CONTROL ISN'T ON THE LINE
MAYBE SOME OF THE REPUBLICANS
SIT OUT, DON.